what's going on guys this is rob and
this is a new show we're launching here
on geek culture explain called the rumor
roundup where we do exactly
what the name suggests which is to round
up all the rumors but really also
including news and different things like
that and to keep things simple we're
gonna keep stuff confined to the marvel
cinematic universe and comic book films
and to start things off
we're not gonna do that and we're gonna
focus on the fact that chadwick boseman
has had his name
attached to howard university's college
of fine arts that's correct howard
university is changing the name of their
college of fine arts 2
the chadwick a boseman college of fine
arts and what a fitting tribute here
right chadwick boseman is a former
graduate howard university is an hbcu or
historically
black college or university this is a
really important thing and it's a
significant thing and i'm glad to see
that chadwick boseman
is still getting some due diligence and
a lot of respect throughout the
worldwide community following his death
he was a very prolific actor not just
for the role he played in black panther
but in the various roles he's played
over the course of his career and to be
quite frank with you guys if he was
still with us today he would probably
become one of hollywood's most prolific
actors
if he wasn't already as far as i'm
concerned michael b jordan
chadwick boseman and john david
washington are the trinity or at least
were the trinity of young black actors
in hollywood
but moving into our segment about comic
book related news and rumors and all
that kind of good stuff christopher
mcdonald also known as
shooter mcgavin in happy gilmore has
been cast in the marvel cinematic
universe
in a role that is undefined in the
secret invasion
film i'm kind of curious what role he's
going to play according to the
deadline.com he's supposedly going to be
playing a role that's wholly unique to
the mcu and before you guys start
freaking out saying this is unheard of
mj from spider-man is actually a
character created for the mcu it does
not stand for mary jane watson that's
what a lot of people thought initially
but that's not the case this is actually
kind of interesting if i'm a betting man
i think he's going to play an
established character in the marvel
cinematic universe
based on marvel comics and if i want to
take it one step further he's going to
play clerk
who's clerk carter's a super scroll he's
essentially a scroll that has the powers
of the fantastic four
it's not overly significant and it's not
a super important thing super scroll was
by no means one of the most important
characters in the history of marvel
comics and if marvel never created him
you would never know the difference
but it would be kind of cool to see a
character from the fantastic four mythos
thrown into the marvel cinematic
universe before the fantastic four
actually appear themselves it'd be a
great way to set the stage for their
upcoming appearance
in the mcu so moving on to our first
rumor of the video supposedly
and don't take this as an absolute truth
supposedly
keanu reeves is going to be in the
marvel cinematic universe i don't know
that's true
but it sounds cool and if it really is
true fans have already decided what role
they want him to play they want him to
play the one above all
and i can't think of a more fitting role
for keanu reeves than to play
the person who's quite literally god in
the entirety of the marvel multiverse
which is a perfect role for keanu reeves
plus he looks the part if you go back
and read sensational spider-man back in
the day the one above all appears he's a
homeless guy but he appears nonetheless
and he looks exactly the way you would
expect keanu reeves to look
if you were playing the one above all
our next bit of news here is a really
really cool one this is really
interesting some of you guys might
consider it a kind of duh moment but
it's actually one of those things that
was up in the air the marvel what if
series will have spider-man centric
episodes i don't know how many they're
going to have it's only a 10 episode
series and supposedly it's all going to
be based on the infinity saga so
who really knows how in-depth these
episodes are going to go but this is a
pretty big piece of news and the reason
why is because as you guys know
spider-man is a sony property
and for a long time people believe that
sony would not allow spider-man to be
used
in any facet of the marvel cinematic
universe outside of the solo spider-man
films and whatever avengers appearances
he would have over the course of the
mcu but to know that he's going to be in
some what-if episodes
is pretty cool because some of the
what-if stories involving spider-man
are really really awesome for example
there's a what-if story based on secret
wars from back in 1984
and while it doesn't necessarily revolve
around spider-man strictly one of the
things that happens that spider-man gets
the venom symbiote just like he did in
the original secret wars
but because they're trapped on the world
and they're never able to leave you
eventually learned the venom symbiote
had actually eaten spider-man and was
basically just walking around in his
bones it was pretty gruesome and really
kind of weird
but it was a really cool moment
involving his character the what if
potential for spider-man
can come from any number of different
things it can come from concepts that
the marvel cinematic universe just
makes up it can be based on stories that
exists within marvel comics there's
really no limit here and that's what
made the what if stories
so fantastic it was really only limited
by a person's imagination but regardless
of what direction they're going to go in
it is good to see that probably the most
popular character in the history of
marvel comics
is going to have an appearance among the
roster and episodes of the characters
we're going to see
over the course of the 10 episode series
so a little bit of bad news
for all you guys who are looking forward
to doctor strange too according to
michael walden the writer of the film
there is no connection between loki and
doctor strange too i know it's a little
bit disappointing it would be cool if
there was one of the things that's been
established recently on behalf of loki
is everything that the time variance
authority will show us
is more or less etched in stone except
not really because you can change the
timeline
i believe that what we're going to see
in loki is going to be more of these are
the things that could happen and whether
or not they do depend on how much you
guys talk about it on social media i
have no idea that's going to be the case
but that's usually what marvel comics
does there's no reason to believe the
marvel cinematic universe would do
anything different but for those
individuals out there who were looking
for a strong connection between loki and
doctor strange too the idea that loki
might lead directly into doctor strange
in the same way that one division will
lead into that film sorry to disappoint
that's apparently not the case but not
all hope is lost
it could be michael waldron's just lying
his ass off we've seen that happen
before in the marvel cinematic universe
actors come out and say no that's not
going to happen at all and then it turns
out to be true so
it could very well be one of these
things where he's just trying to pull
the wool over her eyes and because of
you guys being on social media and being
the detectives that you are
you guys aren't buying it and so we'll
find out once doctor strange two
launches and we'll probably get a much
better idea once the loki series
launches
on june 9th now before we get into our
final rumor here there is a really cool
piece of news that came from marvel
entertainment for all of you podcast
fans
marvel entertainment and siriusxm have
teamed up to launch a 10 episode series
based on old man star-lord or old man
quill if that's what you want to call it
this is basically a story that took
place in the same universe as old man
logan where the villains had basically
conquered earth
it takes place about 30 years into the
future and so by this point peter quill
and rocker raccoon are just a couple
crotchety old people who are really more
dicks than anything else but it is a
hilarious
story it's amazing to see rocket raccoon
and peter quill when they're basically
grumpy old men
minus jack lemmon and walter matthau for
those of you guys who get the reference
it's cool i kind of like it it was cool
to see what the guardians of the galaxy
potentially look like 30 years in the
future where they're all just old and
bitter so make sure you guys keep your
eyes out for that because i know that
i'll be listening to it
i promise this segment is not sponsored
but getting into our final segment here
our last rumor of the night the rumor
here
is that schumachorath is going to appear
in doctor strange too who's shoe magora
those guys who don't know you know how
when you look at a brick wall you have
the bricks and then in between the
bricks you have the mortar that
gray looking stuff that's how the
multiverse works if every single brick
was a universe the mortar would be the
space between the universes
and that's where beans call the mini
angled ones reside they're these great
big huge monstrous tentacle looking
things
that are pretty wild and they almost ate
thanos in the thanos imperative
storyline but the whole thing behind
this is that shumogorath at one point
occupied earth and actually ruled it as
a kind of demon lord he was ultimately
cast out and then he tried to return and
doctor strange had to kill the ancient
one to keep it from happening
probably one of the most significant
doctrine stories in the history of
marvel comics but the cool thing about
this is that supposedly shumagorath is
chasing after a girl named america
chavez
why is he chasing after america chavez
this is a girl that can actually hop
between universes
and so if you're a demonic entity
existing between universes and you want
to actually get into universes what
better person to take over
than a person who can move in between
universes and so america chavez isn't
all that powerful aside from that but it
would be cool to see her in doctor
strange too whether or not those two
beings are actually going to appear
is really anybody's guess and we have to
wait for official castings before we
actually see that but it would kind of
beef up the film a little bit i will say
this though if doctor strange 2 is
largely going to focus on juan division
if we do see america chavez and
schumacher
i don't think we'll see them for very
long at that point it seems like there's
just too much going on in the movie for
it to have a cohesive plot
so if we see them we might only see him
for a moment or two or maybe some kind
of brief explanation about what's going
on perhaps jim gorath might be the
initial villain of the film and then
eventually we move on to wanda being the
prime villain of the film
assuming that that is actually going to
be the case but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching let us know
what you think in the comments section
about this show
and we will catch you all later peace